una grave escasez de combustible es la
expresión de la peor crisis económica de
sri lanka en siete décadas en un intento
desesperado para hacer frente a esta
situación las autoridades cerraron las
escuelas en colombo la capital pidieron
a los empleados públicos que trabajen
desde casa e informaron que sólo
suministran combustible a los servicios
esenciales como la sanidad los trenes y
los autobuses durante dos semanas a
partir del martes los ciudadanos hacen
largas colas para comprar gasolina
llevo aquí desde la medianoche del
viernes cuando llegamos habían dejado de
bombear gasolina no sé si tendré
gasolina o no de momento me han dado un
vale
entretanto una delegación de alto nivel
de los departamentos de tesoro y de
estado de eeuu se reunió con los
dirigentes de la isla para explorar las
formas de brindar ayuda mientras que un
equipo del fondo monetario internacional
llegó para mantener conversaciones sobre
un posible paquete de rescate de tres
mil millones de dólares el país asiático
ya había recibido cuatro mil millones de
dólares de ayuda financiera la india y
las autoridades han hecho un llamado a
la austeridad
la manada carne inicia carbón turu me
ama vio tendremos que enfrentarnos a
varios retos a veces podremos acabar con
las colas de gasolina por completo otras
veces no podremos acabar con las colas
creo que no podremos obtener 550 560
millones de dólares en los próximos
meses definitivamente tendremos que
reducir nuestro consumo a 350 millones
de dólares
para bien de latencia para dolor normal
bucal de youtube la oposición y una gran
mayoría de ciudadanos exigen la dimisión
del presidente gotabaya rajapaksa su
hermano el ex primer ministro magín da
raia pacsa renunció en mayo por la misma
razón la familia es acusada de acaparar
y dar mal manejo a los negocios del
estado precipitando la crisis actual
mientras que la demanda de pasaportes se
ha disparado ya que muchos intentan huir
del país